à l'origine de la crise sociale
l'augmentation du prix du ticket de
métro
une hausse qui fait basculer le pays
dans une contestation inédite depuis les
années pinochet
la hausse du prix des transports publics
de cette fin de semaine était la goutte
qui fait déborder le vase
en réalité cette manifestation va à
l'encontre du système des manifestations
qui dégénèrent en affrontements avec la
police et en pillages faisant plusieurs
morts et de nombreux blessés
malgré l'annulation de la hausse du prix
des transports
le soulèvement continu et le président
au chilien doit décréter l'état
d'urgence
c'est contre ces criminels ils n'ont pas
contre les compatriotes qui manifestent
paisiblement que nous avons invoqué
l'état d'urgence dans le but de les
identifier de les poursuivre de les
juger et de les punir
aussi au cours de la semaine prochaine
je convoquerai une table de dialogue
large et transversales pour entendre la
voix et les propositions des différents
secteurs
mais surtout la voix de nos citoyens
devant la poursuite du mouvement le
président chilien annonce un référendum
pour changer la constitution héritée de
la dictature
une demande des manifestants un an après
le début de la contestation et alors que
le scrutin approche les chiliens
continuent de manifester mais ils sont
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus éthique nous
n'arriverons à une solution qu'une fois
toutes les demandes acceptées tant
qu'elles ne sont pas acceptés tant
qu'elles ne sont pas écrite avec du sang
rien n'aura changé jusqu'à ce que je
sens vraiment que nous avons accompli
quelque chose jusqu'à ce que quelque
chose change parce qu'en ce moment nous
avons un niveau de répression très élevé
il y a encore une énorme injustice
concernant le nombre de blessés et de
morts et de disparus du 18 octobre
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
des demandes qui restent lettre morte
pour l'instant seuls grands acquis ce
référendum dimanche prochain pour
changer la constitution
plus de 14 millions de chiliens sont
appelés à se prononcer